up in the sky
[Music]
[Music]
vo taking grief and turning it into art
[Music]
it ain't no gang without you the Migos
member memorializes the late takeoff his
bandmate and nephew in a new song
without you I wish I had a time machine
[Music]
takeoff died in November after being
shot inside a Houston area bowling alley
cuevo was with him on the night of his
death and this new track offers insight
into his struggle with the loss
is seemingly a reference to cuevo's
Mother Edna Marshall she took in takeoff
and offset cuevo's cousin and raised
them together in 2017 quavo and takeoff
teamed up to buy her a new home as a
Christmas present birthdays ain't the
same without you
Christmas ain't the same without you we
create special moments you did the song
is the first we've really heard from the
remaining Migos members since right
after quavo's death at the time offset
posted a tribute to Instagram writing
quote the pain you have left me with is
unbearable
his wife cardi B opened up about his
struggles to the neighborhood talk but
no lie I have
I have been feeling so hopeless
trying to make my husband happy trying
to make him crack a smile seeing him
randomly Cry takeoff's Lost hit the
hip-hop Community hard in November stars
came together to honor his memory
whenever he would take his Shades off he
had this thing about him that I love no
matter what was going on around us he
was like always
kind of squinting but like his eyes were
wide open
IP take off
we salute you bro oh
damn
we love you bro
[Music]
you know you get to share life-changing
moments with people who change your life
for you know what I'm saying all our
families is when we sit together we eat
together you are affecting culture
across pop music everywhere who doesn't
understand who needs to know you know
whole world need to know if you you know
I'm saying if you're part of the culture
and a part of hip-hop and music you need
to know and his bandmates will continue
to keep that Legacy alive cuevo referred
to take off as his angel in an emotional
letter writing you will continue to send
your blessings down from heaven and I
will continue to keep your name alive as
long as I live tears rolling down
[Music]
I'm sorry
[Music]